so in this video we're gonna try to
think of ways to compute what 31.2 times
19 is and there's multiple ways to
approach this but like always try to
pause this video and see if you can work
through this on your own all right now
let's do this together now one way to
think about this is you could view 31.2
as a certain number of tenths and how
many tenths would this be well you could
view this 31.2 as three hundred and
twelve tenths and so this is the same
thing as three hundred and twelve tenths
times nineteen and so what we could do
is we could figure out what is three
hundred twelve of something times 19 or
what's three hundred twelve times 19 and
it's going to be that many tenths and
then we could convert it back to a
decimal I'll also show another strategy
but let's just do that so if we were to
just multiply 312 times 19 times 19 this
is going to be let's see two obvious in
another color
two times nine is 18 1 times 9 is 9 plus
1 is 10 3 times 9 is 27 plus 1 is 28 if
what I just did looks unfamiliar we have
videos that explain why how this process
works and then we go to the tens place
right over here and so we would say 1
times 2 is 2 1 times 1 is 1 1 times 3 is
3 and then we add everything together we
get 8 0 plus 2 is 2 8 plus 1 is 9 2 Plus
3 is 5 so we get 5 9 to 8 or 5,000 928
now that's not going to be the answer
here the answer is going to be 5
thousand nine hundred and twenty eight
tenths so this is going to be equal to
five thousand nine hundred and twenty
eight tenths now how can we express this
as a decimal well we could think of it
this way if that's the decimal this is
the tenths place this is the ones place
which is the same this is the same thing
as ten tenths place which is the ones
place this is the tens place and this is
the hundreds place well you have
of 8/10 we could put that in the tenths
place you have these twenty tenths
that's the same thing as two ones you
have the nine hundred tents in a
different color nine hundred tents is
the same thing as nine tens and then
your five thousand tenths is the same
thing as five hundreds another way to
think about it is we wrote all the
places out and we wrote it in terms of
tenths so the eight went there and then
every place to the left of that went to
the place to the left of that so this is
going to be five hundred ninety two and
eight tenths so we could write it like
that five hundred ninety two and eight
tenths now another way to approach this
is to just think about the digits not
the actual numbers to figure out well
the answer will have what digits in it
and then try to estimate to think about
where the decimal place should go so for
example you could do 312 times nineteen
so essentially remove the decimal do the
computation and say okay the answer
should have the digits five nine two
eight in that order now where should I
put the decimal in order for that to be
a reasonable answer and that's where
estimation comes in you could say hey
thirty-one point two times nineteen
that's going to be approximately equal
to if I try to estimate these with
numbers that are easy to multiply that's
going to be roughly equal to 30 times 20
which is equal to 600 so that tells me
that my product here should be roughly
equal to 600 and so where would I put
the decimal here for it to be roughly
equal to 600 so I know the answer has
the digits five nine to eight where do I
put a decimal for it to be roughly equal
to 600 well if I were to put the decimal
there that's not roughly equal to 600 if
I were to put the decimal there that's
not roughly equal to 600 that's close to
60 if I put the decimal there that's
close to six if I want to be close to
600 I'd have to put the decimal right
over there and so that's also a good way
to test the reasonableness of what's
going on this should be roughly equal to
600 if we were to estimate it and so we
like that our process got an answer that
is roughly equal to 600